Es ist soweit computer sind tatsächlich in der lage verbrecher zu finden zwar nicht
im vorhinein wie bei minority report
obwohl mayer aber immerhin nach der tat beziehungsweise den taten in den usa bleibt zurzeit tatsächlich jeder zweite mord
umgekehrt wie gar nicht hat sich ein amerikanischer journalist gedacht und hat einen algorithmus konzipiert mit dem sich ungeklärte verbrechen
aufklären lassen mit erfolg und in deutschland da werden algorithmen benutzt sogar um verbrechen vorherzusagen
also, da werden wir dann doch beim 1
Wie das genau funktioniert und was sein algorithmus alles über verbrecher weiß jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen und zum schluss habe ich noch eine ganz besondere überraschung
In deutschland wird das predictive policing genannt gemeint ist damit polizeiarbeit die auf computer vorhersagen
basiert minority report lässt grüßen in bayern baden-württemberg beispielsweise
laufen dazu pilotprojekt eine software in deutschland entwickelt sagt voraus
wo einbrecher demnächst zu schlagen werden das ganze basiert auf der annahme dass täter und täterinnen natürlich auch nach mustern
arbeiten dass sie beispielsweise orte bevorzugen an denen das gute
fluchtmöglichkeiten gibt oder aber dass sie in erfolgreiche gebiete zurückkehren und wieder zuschlagen genau das sagt die software voraus und wenn sie sich zumindest
70 sicher ist schlägt sie alarm dann werden polizisten und natürlich
Polizistinnen an diesen ort geschickt vielleicht ist das die polizeiarbeit der zukunft in den usa
Hat sich der amerikanische journalist thomas hahn und eigenständig eine ähnliche software
gebastelt angestachelt und motiviert wurde er durch den sogenannten
zettel river killer dieser serienmörder hat 48 frauen auf dem gewissen ein foto des killers an seinem schreibtisch
Erinnert ihn immer wieder an die dringlichkeit seiner idee mit hilfe eines algorithmus
Verbrecher jagen eigentlich war thomas tage auf polizeireporter und hat auch immer mal wieder aus dem waisenhaus
Berichtet aber die zahlreichen ungeklärten morde in den usa die ließ ihm einfach keine ruhe und somit finger tatsächlich an das größte
mordfall archiv der usa anzulegen mehr als
750.000 mordfälle hat er hier archiviert und übertrumpfte damit sogar das bei dessen archiviert tatsächlich
27.000 mordfälle weniger zählen ihn zukommt in den usa gibt es keine nationalen datenbanken dagegen stehen etwa
220.000 ungelöste mordfälle dazu haar auf in einem interview die einzige möglichkeit herauszufinden dass zwei morde zusammenhängen
Ist dass sich zwei ermittler zufällig in der kantine treffen und ihre fälle vergleichen
Seine konkrete idee die entwicklung einer software die gemeinsamkeiten der verbrechen identifiziert wie wurde das opfer getötet
Wurde das verbrechen gegangen und um welche opfer handelt es sich alle infos zu den morden der letzten drei jahrzehnte
wurden ins archiv aufgenommen und das computerprogramm machte sich an die arbeit nach möglichen
Gemeinsamkeiten der unterschiedlichen mordfälle zu suchen und es hat tatsächlich geklappt der software war beispielsweise
aufgefallen dass es in indianer 15 ungeklärte todesfälle gab und zwar mit frappierenden
gemeinsamkeiten die opfer allesamt frauen wurden erwürgt und in verlassenen häusern
aufgefunden doch die polizei dort ignorierte die hinweise von thomas harloff einen serienmörder
Im eigenen bezirk undenkbar doch der ehemalige journalist war hartnäckig
zudem passierten weitere sieben morde auch diese opfer wurden erwürgt erst dann handelte die polizei
mittlerweile sitzt der killer hinter gittern und hat weitere sechs morde gestanden
Das fatale auch diese morde waren bis dahin von der polizei nicht als morde erkannt worden
tatsächlich ein großes problem in den usa
5000 menschen töten dort pro jahr ohne dass sie dafür bestraft werden und die aufklärungsquote
sinkt sogar in deutschland sieht die statistik etwas anders aus zumindest sagen dass die
Offiziellen zahlen der polizei demnach werden ihr mehr als 90 prozent der morde aufgeklärt
es gibt allerdings auch kritiker die diese hohe erfolgsquote in frage stellen das
wissen von hamburgs datenbank zu serien killern jedenfalls ist
Gigantisch die morde werden demnach zehnmal häufiger von männern als von. Frauen begangen die täter
Sind meistens nicht sehr intelligent und die opfer sind in mehr als 70 prozent der fälle
weiblich und zwischen 20 und 50 jahren alt spannend auch die folgenden effects rechtshänder fliehen meistens in die linke richtung
werfen spuren die sie belasten könnten allerdings eher nach rechts thomas adolph hat es also tatsächlich geschafft computern beizubringen
serienmörder zu enttarnen
daran beteiligt ist auch seine gemeinnützige organisation mörder accountability project mpp
mittlerweile hat der ehemalige journalist ein gewisses standing
einen neuen hinweise an die polizei in cleveland nahm die behörden tatsächlich sehr ernst und haben eine sondereinheit
abgestellt denn thomas adolph hat mit hilfe seiner datenbank indizien entdeckt dass dort womöglich ein serienkiller sein unwesen treibt und mittlerweile bereits
60 frauen auf dem gewissen hat und der algorithmus kann noch, mehr
Er hat eine wirklich verblüffende erkenntnisse ans tageslicht gebracht demnach starten viele zukünftige mörder ihre karriere als
brandstifter thomas adolph sucht also mittlerweile auch nach brandstiftern und er ist nicht mehr allein mittlerweile haben sich zahlreiche
Hobbydetektive wagen geschlossen die seine datenbank nutzen um serienmörder zu entfernen und das ist genau das was haben doch wollte
zitate wir wollen uns dass wir eine online version zur verfügung stellen können wir hoffen sehr dass polizei
Detektive und auch die öffentlichkeit des nutzen werden um potenzielle
gefahren zu
Identifizieren wer und jetzt gibt's das ganz besonderes zehn jahre clixoom und da habe ich mir gesagt
Dieses jahr könnte auf jeden fall
Mal persönlich zu mir kontakt aufnehmen und zwar alle und das wird gehen mit whatsapp
meldet euch bei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr als erste von den neuesten videos
garantiert und ihr könnt direkt mit mir chatten und themenvorschläge machen oder andere ideen vorschlagen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
Probiert es mal aus und ja hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klicken hast du ihn bedrohen die erde
jederzeit und auch nicht vergessen natürlich zu abonnieren und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran ich freue mich auf zahlreiche anmeldungen